ah wow okay if i had to bring in
food to the bubble i have no i i have to
keep thinking that's tough
in the bubble i do have to look up on
google maps
a lot of restaurants there have been
some trial and error
um figuring out what i like and what's
in this area that were able to get
delivered to us
i love sandwiches because you can't
really go wrong with a sandwich that you
customize yourself
marucci's and wanna create i would
always go to if the line wasn't too long
my go-to sandwich was a number five
which was
with turkey bacon lettuce on a ciabatta
roll
organ will always have a special place
in my heart the biggest
pregame meal we had was at banangiani's
i know we're undefeated eating there it
was before the usa game
we all were like uh this might ruin our
streak here of eating here and being
undefeated
and then we ended up winning and so we
were like there's something about this
food
i'm definitely looking forward to a lot
of things getting to new york obviously
playing and starting my professional
career but
there's a lot of other things that i'm
looking forward to which is obviously
the food spots
and hopefully fall in love with some new
sandwich shop in new york
those are my hidden gems thank you
bleacher report in google
[Music]